welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar the intersection
of nutrition microbiome and medical
cannabis presented by dr. Deborah Kim
--less medical director of forward grow
my name is execute Aris and I will be
your moderator for today's we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin I would I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
as educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to attain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Kim Lewis Oh
announcer in the presentation over to
her thank you and thank you to everyone
at lab roots for providing this platform
so that I can discuss my favorite topic
the intersection of nutrition the
microbiome and medical cannabis so
before I start I am the medical director
of forward grow a cultivation and
processing company Maryland and I'm
consulting for pure green canna a
processing elimination company in
Michigan and I have no actual and
potential conflict of interest in
relation to this presentation so the POC
Racine road before you kill someone ask
him if he's willing to give up the
things that make him sick and misquote
resonates with me and as you will see I
needed to figure out what would be the
disrupter the thing that people could do
to help themselves prevent an eel
disease
currently our healthcare system is such
that patients passively medicine but it
is given to them but yet they do nothing
to prevent or even help heal illness so
it started out as a thought experiment
and it started out like this
what if prior to beginning any medical
treatment even cannabis medicine what if
we changed our internal milieu what if
we could create an internal environment
that can actually be receptive to
healing and what if that process of
changing the body's internal environment
is really not that difficult and all we
have to do is change the foods we eat
food is known to create or destroy our
health chronic diseases are directly
linked to poor eating habits I don't
think that's much of a surprise but the
question is what does that mean how do
we implement this there's so much
information and misinformation in the
media that talks about what we should
and should not eat though let me be
clear I'm talking about whole food all
plant diet no processed foods I'm
intentionally not using the V word even
because coca-cola Oreo cookies then my
daughter says even some pop-tarts or
vegan I'm talking about real food down
teenager no animal products including
their sugar dairy fish no chicken
nothing with a face nothing that we can
cut it and nothing that comes from a
mother and no processed foods including
no added oils though if you implement
this what will that do by changing your
diet eating only plants our body's
internal environment actually transforms
and this transformation makes the body
more receptive to one so why am I
talking about food in a cannabis
conference because I want everyone to
understand the why and the how I treat
and the patients that I treat are
predominantly cancer patients which is
interesting because I'm an
anesthesiologist and a medicine doctor
so I feel that if you're a cancer
patient and you're coming to me for help
we need to do something incredibly
different to help maximize the options
that help you maintain and getting the
best life in addition to a diet change I
also use medical cannabis for some
patients the medical cannabis I use is
something called a micro dose of
cannabis oil extract and so I'm now
going to show you how I do it
so in medical school we were taught that
our immune system functions a lot better
in an aberrant environment than any an
acid one I thought that was a pretty big
statement and it was followed up by
nothing no one gave us any tips or
tricks as to what that means and so this
big statement like a lot of other things
I've learned in medical school was just
that a statement that there is no
guidance so the question is how do we
change our pH so in the operating room
is an anesthesiologist I work there and
if somebody's blood gas test comes back
with a low pH there are a lot of
different maneuvers that we can use to
change the page however life is not an
operating room and those tricks are just
that and it's a temporary fix purpose of
changing the community is to prevent
your health treat chronic disease so
that's why I mandate a whole food or
plant diet however I needed proof 1
proving to myself that this made sense
and to in order to help patients
understand this so that they are they
get on board um I have to prove it to
them as well so I started looking into
the literature and showing the Journal
of environmental Public Health in 2012
they published a survey of literature to
see what impact of anything was the
effect of an alkaline diet on a bunch of
different health benchmarks so they
certainly examined an alcohol diet and
back pain growth hormone muscle bone
disease rolls peach on various cells
organs and membranes and what they found
was that increased fruits and vegetables
in an alkaline diet may actually benefit
bone health it can reduce muscle wasting
as well as mitigate other chronic
illnesses such as high blood pressure
and Stroke result an increase in growth
hormone then alkaline diet or an
elevation in their pH would improve
outcomes from cardiovascular health to
memory and cognition in the alcohol
resulting in added benefit for some to
most ever be agents and be sure to get
those types of things for cancer that
require a higher pH but I find it
interesting that the conclusion of this
survey after all of these
health-promoting effects was this it
would be prudent to consider an alkaline
diet to reduce morbidity mortality of
chronic disease I'm imagining that if
there was a pharmaceutical drug there in
any one of these things I think that the
language used by the drug company would
be a lot different in 2001 in the
Journal of leukocyte biology it also
examined what happens to the immune
system and immune cells and in acid pH
versus an alcohol pH and the upshot of
this study was that the immune system
actually works better in an appalling pH
so how do we implement this change I
can't just leave this as a statement
like I learned in medical school and not
how to figure out what we can give it
would ends up the most effective method
to change our internal you from an acid
pH to an appalam pH is to by eating a
whole food plant diet with no animal
products no processed or prepackaged
foods and no I need oils and so I'd have
my patients test their morning urine
every morning on a urine pH district to
make sure that their alkaline because
they will see the importance of even if
they slip for a day the pH actually does
alter accordingly and also we're all in
nf1 not everybody is the same so some
people handle things differently even if
it falls under the category of an all
plant diet so it's a good monitor to
gauge whether or not they're eating
properly for themselves
the whole food verses again I have to
also prove that because vegan has a lot
of popularity and we need to discuss the
differences and so there continues to be
a big disconnect regarding the
information between what veganism is
what proper food is when the diet is and
so I found this article in a magazine
called the week in March of 2018 and it
was under the topic of health scare over
the week they published this little
blurb linking processed foods to cancer
and they shared a staggering statistic
it says that for every 10% increase in
the consumption of processed foods there
was an Associated Wells percent increase
in cancerous so if you take a bag of
snack sized potato chips believe it or
not it's about 300 calories if you eat a
2,000 calorie diet there's our first
bump of a 12% increase in cancer risk
considering most Americans eat
predominantly processed foods as their
daily food consumption this statistic
should have been sending out warnings to
every media channel every health care
provider every hospital every school
lunch program I know I haven't seen or
heard anything more in this article in a
blurb in a non medical journal so here's
another interesting study in 2005 this
reported a study done by Dean Ornish and
this was reported in Journal of
neurology basically what they did was
take a group of young healthy men who
eat a standard American diet they took
their blood and on a petri dish
they had cleaned it out Andrews
independent cancer cells and they
dripped these healthy men's blood on
these cancer cells and they saw that
they saw
pressed cancer growth by 9% because
these were otherwise young healthy men
and their immune system functioned
somewhat so then what they did was they
changed in his groups of men's diets to
a whole food all plant diet no processed
foods and the lighted oils and they did
this for a year it came back repeated
the study took their blood picture -
played it out some cancers for them
prostate cancer cells turns it on and
found a 70% reduction in prostate cancer
cell growth this was without therapy
this was without any special anything
other than a diet change so then they
repeated this study this time they used
women and they used three different
breast cancer cell types so he took
women on a standard American diet they
were otherwise healthy they played it
out three different breast cancer cell
types on a petri dish and through the
blood and the dark columns showed that
there was a reduction of slight
reduction in breast cancer cell growth
in these women they put these women on a
whole food all plant diet no processed
foods no added oil for only two weeks
and repeated this study and these
results are incredible if you look at
the hatch hatched marked columns it
shows that that there was a
statistically significant reduction in
tumor growth in all three cancer lines
so slowing cancer growth is great but
what would be better would be killing
cancer cells so again they took these
same women or otherwise healthy the
standard American diet three separate
cancer cell lines put it in a petri dish
the dark columns showed as a reduction
in cancer development lately
two weeks later same women and
whole food all plant diet the hatch
marks the hatch marks column those a
statistically significant increase in
breast cancer cell death in all three
lines and not occurred in only two weeks
of diet change now if this isn't
compelling enough to change people's
diets I don't know what is so what about
oil why am I talking about oil oil is a
whole food right and oil can come from
vegetables right olive oil and soybean
oil and such so there are cells in our
body that line our blood vessels and
they're called the endothelium so we
originally believed we meeting the
medical consultant community originally
believed that the end of William was a
vascular lining that really had no other
bodily function however in the 1980s
scientists learned the endothelium
actually played a very active an
important role in our biologic functions
in fact what are the roles is that deep
that the endothelium is one of our
largest endocrine glands it secretes a
chemical called nitric oxide nitric
oxide is a potent dilator on blood
vessels and regulates blood pressure the
high blood pressure will occur without a
functioning endothelial layer and nitric
oxide secretion is integral in this and
so how does oil play a role in this oil
actually destroys that beautiful carpet
of those end of the video cells that
line our blood vessels at oil and comes
from any source including vegetables so
there was a study that looked at oil
coming from soybeans palm oils and olive
oil you all created a similar
detrimental effect on the endothelial
function healthy people imagine what it
does in so what if you eat a lot of
fruit vegetables and you're saying well
what if I only have a little bit of meat
and a little bit of dairy how does that
work on my endothelium and sadly even if
it's plant derived and even if it's a
small amount of animal it worsens
endothelial function and if you walk
into a room where nobody's genetically
related and you no reason ask somebody
over the age of 40 who has high blood
pressure the majority of people or raise
their hands and the reason why is not
that we're genetically related the
reason why is because we all eat a
similar type diet okay so how is the
microbiome fit into this so there are
microorganisms living on within us in
fact there are more micro organisms on
us and within us than there are us and
again science and medical community
originally thought that we all live
together but separately and then each of
us did not act interact with each other
but now we know that is very wrong and
then the microbiome is integral is
integrated into our biological processes
and so our diet and food affect us our
diet and food in fact them we can affect
microbiome and the microbiome in fact us
what does this mean so remember their
old adage who are you eat we know that
that's true but what also is true is
they are what we so when we eat a diet
and whole food all plants no process no
animals or
animal derivatives and no added oil we
actually cultivate a microbiome that
creates substances called short chain
fatty-acids
these short chain fatty acids help to
maintain the integrity of the intestinal
cell junctions that help prevent toxins
from getting into our system
this is otherwise called a leaky gut and
that leaky gut can cause inflammation
and an intact cell line Junction will
prevent that inflammation from happening
and these short chain fatty-acids
in and of themselves are highly
anti-inflammatory we eat a standard
American diet animals processed food
junk food oil and foods that we think
are good but not like lean meats those
skin on white meat chicken were wild
heart fish we end up cultivating a
microbiome that secretes chemicals that
this third intestinal cell junctions
this leads to a systemic or our total
body exposure to toxins and inflammation
and the micro environment gets created
by eating those types of foods also
secrete chemicals that are
pro-inflammatory which leads to chronic
illness so the interesting thing is that
we're not victims here we actually have
the power but alter the composition of
our microbiome and therefore help our
own intestinal health and systemic
health until I found an article in July
of 2017 from in JAMA and it was titled
starch based superfood may protect
against a variety of diseases and this
article actually supports the positive
aspects of short chain fatty acids yet
conclusion is a little bit different
than what I concluded the conclusion in
the Jama article
was we will now have to wait Performa to
develop a short chain fatty acid pill
I don't think so research has shown that
the microbiome can influence positively
or negatively all of these medical
conditions from diabetes to cancer
deliver disease to autoimmune issues
finding heart issues and kidney problems
insomnia obesity and autism and hiv/aids
by altering your microbiome lieutenant
influence positively or negatively all
of these things so what we put in our
mouths actually matters
so I guess the question is why are we
discussing a whole plant nutrition when
everybody was expecting a candida stalk
the reason is when I was studying about
the microbiome dawned on me and it looks
that biologic influences look
surprisingly like the constellation of
diseases and conditions for which
medical cannabis is often recommended so
this is why I mandated diet change
t-shirts are desperate to heal and they
have literally exhausted all traditional
medical options
they're sick and dying they're coming to
me he's an anesthesiologist not an
oncologist then clearly they have a
serious problem I want to give them the
possible chance
there's no panacea of course however
look above data that I just presented I
think it only makes sense
the truth is that we humans all of us
whether we're sick or not be eating this
way to prevent chronic illness hopefully
someday this information will resonate
with the healthcare community and
actually resonated with the general
population as well so now on to the
cannabis part so cannabis
interacts with a biologic system that
all of us have people in fact almost
every living thing has it and it's
called the endocannabinoid system endo
means endogenous or within now that or
it means it our own body these chemicals
that are similar to the chemicals that
the cannabis plant makes just like our
body makes chemicals called endorphins
similar to what the popping plant makes
marine opium and to the purpose of our
endocannabinoid system is to maintain
homeostasis or physiologic balance what
does that mean it means that our own
endocannabinoid system is involved in
every single biologic system in our
bodies from thinking to pooping and
everywhere in between ok then don't even
know about this endocannabinoid system
not taught in biology class I certainly
didn't learn it in medical school or
residency or any of the tens of
thousands of dollars and hours that of
CME credits that I had to eat to
maintain my medical license besides the
fact that cannabis has been speeding
tires elements in the endocannabinoid
system were only recently discovered the
late 1980s and the late 1990s and we're
still learning more and more and the
reason is different from an organ based
system where you can actually open up
somebody and see how hard or a lung or
liver and different from a cellular
based system where you can look at
slides under a microscope
endocannabinoid system is a chemical
based system it took a long time before
they were able to identify it describe
it briefly the endocannabinoid system is
made up of endocannabinoids which are
endogenous chemicals that we made the
most notable or a EA or an animai and
waking receptors which eats
endocannabinoids interact with and the
most like just
Gustus cb1 and cb2 but there are lots of
other receptors that they interact with
it's fully done to find more and the
enzymes that meet the endocannabinoids
and break them down
the interesting thing about the indira
cannabinoids is that they're made on
demand and use locally and they're
rapidly broken down and they're not
stored and that will play an important
role in the next conversation white oak
cannabinoids it's just a fancy word for
the plants chemicals interact with our
bodies and no cannabinoid receptors so
briefly the cannabis plant is literally
a chemical manufacturing Factory
it makes over 400 chemicals 100 of which
are specific to the plant known as bio
cannabinoids there's over 100 terpenes
these are the chemicals that give the
scent in taste
via canvas plant flavonoids which
provides color and are our antioxidants
and anti-inflammatory and the
interesting thing is intoxication and
you know high that everybody ascribes to
the canvas close by only a few of those
over a hundred plus cannabinoids and of
the non-intoxicating cannabinoids they
have tremendous bio activity the
interesting thing about that is that
many people just think about cannabis is
being THC but really it's all of the
cannabinoids and turkeys and flavonoids
that work together hold the entourage
effector synergistic effect and that
works better than Marinol and for those
of you that don't know what Marinol is
it's a synthetic THC
it's the 1980s we as physicians were
allowed to prescribe it to any patient
they can be prescribed this across 50
states without worrying about any
federal a legality
get on trips with you why then does it
is it not used because without the whole
plant benefit marital just doesn't work
as well so now coming full circle
endocannabinoids canvas and the
microbiome it seems that the role of the
endocannabinoid system is directly
involved in that brain gut access that
talks to the brain through and through
the microbiome and through our enteric
nervous system an endocannabinoid system
is intricately involved studies that
show that endocannabinoids are there at
the crossroads between the gut
microbiota and our metabolism
cannabinoid signaling regulates
inflammation and energy balance
importance of the green the brain gut
access and so it seems that it's been
known for some time that the brain can
modulate the gut that's like a gut
feeling with endocannabinoids it appears
that the gut and also modify the brain
the whole thing is if you're connected
which is why we're having this
conversation last but not least I want
to talk about why producing because this
is how I began in my patients who's a
medical cannabis is needing the term
micro dose is a term of art it doesn't
mean 10 to the minus 6 it really is a
technique for studying behavior of drugs
and humans where the doses are so low
they're unlikely to produce the whole
body effect and high enough to allow for
a cellular response the reason why this
is so important is that often vilified
teas
Seaford's intoxicating effects it small
amounts of teens Nicomedia beneficial in
patients and it depends on the amount of
THC one uses that will determine whether
there's intoxication use small amounts
what species tend to look so interesting
phyto cannabinoids or different than our
end ok
so that chemicals from the plant taking
it generally taking internally different
methods of consumption it confers
systemic effects it is stored in fat
because these chemicals are highly fat
soluble and because it's stored in fat
it acts as a Depot for a slow release
and just to remind you the
endocannabinoids the chemicals our own
body mates he's made on demand used
locally rapidly broken down and not
stored and so my thought was if that's
the case why don't cannabinoids or the
chemicals from the plant are held in our
body for a period of time why would we
need a lot of them and so this was my
idea of what constitutes a low dose or a
microdose so general dose is if you have
a joint which is a gram which is a
thousand milligrams I promise this is
the only methyl okay today and 20% of
that cannabis plant is THC there will be
200 milligrams of change see if we were
to smoke that joint 30 to 40 percent is
lost the sidestream smoke and ash you'll
only get about 60 to 80 milligrams and
we're not talking about on microdose I'm
talking about less than 2 milligrams of
total cannabinoid cane ECM CBD and any
of the other minor cannabinoids as well
of course I had to go to the literature
to support my hypothesis until
aggressing it out in 2006 did a very
similar study as the vegans study that I
described using a petri dish cancer
cancer cell lines grow out putting
people's blood on it they put different
cannabinoids and then different
fractions you can see rich with some
rich solutions you see what would slow
down answer growth and this is a very
busy slide that reports you to micro
moles and when you do the conversion for
micro moles two milligrams using
Avogadro's equation you will see it in
micro door
actually make sense so now I'm going to
discuss some patients as examples of how
I treat them soon successes though these
are two prostate cancer patients the
first one is a 72 year old man and had a
recurrent prostate cancer diagnosis was
diagnosed in 2011 and 2015
yes they started to rise in 2016 this
PSA level went to 7.8 and that leaves
biopsy revealed recurrent cancer
unfortunately is cat scan killed no
metastases he began his first of three
new porn injections and the problem was
he didn't respond after the first one
after a month his PSA remained at 7.8
and he was concerned that he was not
going to able to be treated effectively
so we started him on his diet low dose
cannabis oil continue to second it
through Friday injection because I never
changed the traditional therapy possible
so this slide shows in blue his first
month of the brown injection second one
shows blue the second loop on injection
and the red is when we introduced its
diet change and these ludos cannabis oil
so again the low dose cannabis oil was
less than 2 milligrams per ml of total
cabin weed it was a subliminal oil that
goes under the tongue and he used one
one milliliter four times a day and
after the second month is KS a was
almost cut in half
we continued first third month his PSA
dropped two point three he's fourth
month he no longer zoned in crime it
would maintain two point three in fifth
month this is 2015
this is 2019 now and his PSA remains on
one this is a eighty one-year-old
otherwise healthy man or the Warner
history of metastatic prostate cancer
sadly he was true he was treated with
seed implants radiation and Lupron
injections and sadly it was refractory
to that we continue to have escalating
testosterone levels he was ready to have
surgery to remove his testosterone
generating organ which was his testicles
clearly he didn't want that surgery so
it came to me and we started him on
ludos cannabis oil his time we treated
him five times a day and just diet and
so his testosterone levels started at a
high level of thirteen hundred and fifty
milligrams per deciliter and only in two
weeks after a diet change and
cannabinoids he was cut in half he went
to a surgeon and said what do you think
I dropped by almost half and the surgeon
thought it was incredible he said but
it's still too high then you still need
to do surgery and the patient asked for
two more weeks and he dropped in two
more weeks
he's testosterone level dropped lower
than what they weren't expected from his
if he had surgery there are a lot of
studies that show cannabinoids and
prostate cancer and how it can bring
cancer to patients so the first case is
a 69 year-old man who woke up in the
emergency room after having the surgery
and MRI revealed that he had a tumor
biopsy diagnosed him with the Cleo
blastoma he was discharged from the
hospital he was incredibly lethargic he
was unable to perform his activities of
daily living without assistance and in
tremendous cognitive changes the only
medicine they put her mom was tegretol
for her seizures this is his MRI when he
was diagnosed in the hospital and now
white mass shows a large glioblastoma in
an area of the brain that was not
amenable to surgery and when they did a
biopsy and tested for these and was
there
it was resistant to chemotherapy they
usually do so his only ability was to
have radiation therapy he changed his
diet starter mom low-dose cannabis oil
four times up okay somehow somebody
ordered an MRI only two weeks later and
this is his post two weeks and the
radiology report reads central cystic
degeneration clearly responding to
radiation therapy continual
unfortunately or fortunately he didn't
see the radiation oncologist that was
scheduled for two more weeks so this is
what it was pre and post and this was
nine months later and again there are a
lot of studies looking at different
cannabinoids cannabis as a whole regard
to treatment of cancers next patient and
this is the one that always shows down
my spine and I loved in my throat this
is story of an eight-year-old girl with
acute lymphocytic leukemia he found
multiple chemotherapy radiation trials
held bone marrow transplant and was in
Hospice she's complains from the parents
regarding her was chronic nausea lack of
appetite headache and lack of energy he
was lethargic upon my evaluation and not
really communicative he looks swollen
and the only medicines that she had was
methadone and morphine in divided doses
and her MRI in hospice or prior to going
into hospice was this thenn wait is
either bone or bad Boone on the outside
is her skull no I mean the weight on the
outside is her skull the white horns on
the where the brain is choose the left
to an angel spread of her other cancer
so the goals are to prove
quality of life before she died you try
to get get a handle of her pain she
tried to transition her off opiates you
helped her enjoy her last days we start
her on oral sublingual four times a day
and we changed her diet so the response
was interesting initially when we were
able to reduce and replace all of the
opiates became more active she started
to appropriate demeanor which means that
she was talking back to her mother
refusing to take a shower or a bath and
I believe I Rowling was involved mother
said this was not responsive the
reaction of a dying child and demanded
another MRI MRI revealed a mass
deduction of cancer and a brain this is
the before and after this was in 2015
and so he transitioned her from hospice
to second grade and he's nearing first
grade whatever anyway lots of studies
that show how cannabis works with lung
cancer this is a story of a 15 year old
female smoker and in 2060 diagnosed with
a metastatic adeno carcinoma of the lung
he had a left lower lung removal and you
know putting her they were going to put
her on chemo and radiation she's given
me less than a 10% five-year survival
the changed her diet 30 monthly dose
cannabis oil interesting thing who's not
every success is about about living or
dying it's about quality of life as well
she was evil tuned or traditional
therapy her chemotherapy he was able to
maintain weight by eating had no nausea
and vomiting he's able to go to work
every day do her activities of daily
living those lives throughout her entire
chemo radiation treatment interesting
than enough
he's still alive and well and again
there are lots of studies that show
importance of Atticus in regard to the
treatment of a lot of symptomatic
effects of traditional therapeutic
treatments as well as with cancer it
sounds so I hope this was a compelling
discussion understanding the importance
of having a proper internal environment
using the food as medicine yeah he'll
heal and prevent disease and if needed
medical cannabis in the proper amounts
seems to make a lot of sense I want to
thank you for listening and giving me
this opportunity to share my passion
with you well thank you dr. Kim list for
that informative presentation I would
also like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through june of 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye